[Music]
[Music]
this is
the ramsay show you can be intentional
about your character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host you jump in we'll talk
about your life and your money it's a
free call
and some say the advice is worth what
you pay for it
flying solo today the phone number is
triple eight eight two
five five two two five that's triple
eight eight
two five five two two five melissa in
new york city starts us
off this hour hey melissa how are you
hey thank you very much for taking your
call it's been much appreciated
absolutely how can we help okay i have
some um
i might have some you know for me it's
exciting but my husband's going to be
retiring
and he has the final papers to fill out
and i figured you're the best person to
ask his question
he's being offered 1.6 million dollars
to retire
for his pension payments
and i really don't know which way to go
because there's so many options so a
lump sum a lump sum on the pension is
1.6
well correct so you can get a 1.6
million dollar
correct payout
that's not a retirement package that
they're paying him compensation to
retire
that's his pension correct okay all
right
so that will have to be rolled over
right into a um you know like a
retirement
you know you know you get it so it
differs so no
no tax implications right away right or
he has an
option to take like he can has options
like 25 50 75 or 100 for
survivorship right for you or for or for
your heirs beyond you
yeah correct okay so obviously you can
only choose one so
obviously you picked me but um he would
he would offer the 100 survivorship
if anything um you know they make it
they make it very attractive the only
surviving one generation past
you though after that it's gone yes sir
that is correct yeah
so ultimately the money either
evaporates
or it stays in your family it stays
it only stays in your family if you take
the lump sum
and you roll it to an ira correct
correct
yeah so you take it okay
and the how was the pension payments
because i'm just so scared with the
market
and what's going on and you know my
husband taught me i'm crazy not to take
it
for not to take the lump sum yeah we can
make money on the lump sum
now go back and sit down with your
investment advisor if you don't have one
get with a smartvestor pro and sit down
right and look at how old are you guys
he's 55 and i'm 50. okay and look at the
market
look at the market for the last 40 or 50
years
okay and you can even there are some
charts that are interesting to look at
which will help you with your nerves
okay that that
have the worst day here's what happened
in on black monday in 1987. here's what
happened
uh when the market went down at the end
of the bush beginning
of the obama administration 2008.
here's what happened after 9 11. here's
what happened
spring of covid yes
okay which as an example it went down
dramatically
for 57 days right or went down
down dramatically and it took 57 days to
recover we did not know that
when because we did not know what covid
was going to do to our economy
right correct but the only way you would
assume that you would not
ride this roller coaster out from the
bottom back up would be
you would have to make the assumption
that the economy is entirely collapsing
same in 2008 same in 911.
same if you go back into the carter
administration same
if you go back to here's a weird one in
the late 1950s the stock market
shot way down when the russians
launched the first satellite and beat us
into space
sputnik actually you can see a stock
market change on these geopolitical
issues the assassination of osama bin
laden
she's a spike upward you know and so on
so these are these are issues that don't
have anything to do with finance but
that end up driving the market on a
short term
because the market is also driven by
emotions so it helps you to look at that
and it helps you to go okay
how long did it take to after the planes
hit the towers and the stock market was
literally closed for two days because
the wall street is right there on that
tip of manhattan
and then when it finally did reopen it
tanked it dropped 500 points in 20
minutes
right i remember that i remember most
people don't remember is is that in 47
days it returned
right and better than ever exactly and
shot
in there and never looked back uh it
went down to 6 500 in 2008 it's at 35
000 the dow is this week
so right yeah you've got to get you got
to get those numbers kind of down in
your heart or you're going to freak out
with this idea
now once you've done that once you've
done that then here's what you're going
to discover the
average on the stock market return since
it began is a little over 11 between 11
and 12
depending on how you want to measure it
somewhere in there right this pension is
paying out at about seven percent
okay so if you run your pension numbers
on the 1.6 million you're gonna see
seven percent of their abouts
okay depending on which survivorship you
choice you pick but that's what that
that number of dollars annually on
as a return on 1.6 will be right around
there so you're going to get more money
while you're alive
in mutual funds and you're going to get
more money
when he dies in mutual funds
by rolling it by rolling it to there so
it at least my
children can have it to them and it
doesn't disappear
upon the death your children and their
children's children and their children's
children
here's another interesting thing if you
don't touch it
and you just live off of something else
and you invested in in that it'll double
about every seven years
well he's got he's got about a million
in his 401k plan now yeah
so yeah if we take 1.6 just talking
about this one discussion
you know it's gonna be 3.2 after seven
years at 62.
at 69 it would be about seven
and at 76 it'll be 14.
14 what nine million
yeah and that all goes to your kiddos
and their kiddos kiddos and so on
as long as you know and a hundred
percent of the time it does not go to
them if you
leave it in this stinking pension so you
take the rollover
and you roll it in a direct transfer
traditional ira which you've already
researched you've already discovered
there are no taxes
and you invested in a good mix of mutual
funds i'm
60 i'm older than you guys mine is
invested across the four types that we
talk about here on the air
one-fourth in growth growth and income
aggressive growth and international all
mutual funds that have long
10-year or more track records
all mutual funds that have outperformed
the index
for the area that they are in meaning
the stock market
so they're doing better than the market
on average and have a track record of
that
and 100 of that money will pass to my
heirs
it will not be left behind for the
pension plan
there's very few times folks that you
won't take the lump sum on a pension and
that's the reason
because you lose it all when you die
that's it you get zero
it's easy math this is the ramsey show
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children
and we had also just started a real
estate company and needed to find health
care coverage that would meet our needs
we were attracted to chm because of its
low monthly costs
and the ability to negotiate medical
costs down established in 1981
and accredited by the better business
bureau chm is here to meet the needs of
your growing family or small business
check us out at ch.ministries.org
backslash budget
we absolutely believe in it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
our question of the day is from
blinds.com a wonderful american company
you can find out for yourself why
blinds.com
is the number one online retailer of
custom window coverings free samples
free shipping
the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more use the promo code
ramsey to get the best
possible deal you know i bought blinds
from these guys many times and we've
endorsed them for over a decade now
you know why they take care of you guys
today's question comes from debra in
arkansas
my 90 year old mom recently recently
received 300 000
from the sale of her home she now lives
in independent living residence at a
cost of four thousand dollars a month
she received about fifteen hundred a
month from social security
she has no debt she's cognitive
ambulatory and in good health for her
age
someone from her bank called me to talk
about investment options for the three
hundred thousand
should she invest any of these funds or
just let it sit in her bank savings
account
if she should invest then how
much well
it's a touchy subject
if we're parking it for her peace of
mind
we can park it in a savings account it
will make absolutely nothing
which is the bank's goal and um she'll
make nothing and she'll lose nothing
and she'll have that nest egg just
sitting there
she the likelihood of her burning
through it and while she's alive
at her age statistically would be zero
because you only need a couple thousand
bucks a month twenty four thousand and
two
uh she just lived over a hundred
and that's not gonna you know likely
statistically not likely to happen do
people lived over and yes they do but
that's not
statistically um were i her
was it me if i was 90
i would not be handling this money for
my own use
i would be handling it to pass on
in which case i would want it to work a
little harder than a stinking bank
account and so i personally
would invest it because i'm very
comfortable with that but i would not
want her to do that
unless she was very comfortable with
that because she's not really investing
it for herself she's
investing it for whoever is going to
inherit it
and so during the next
five years that she lives 10 years that
she lives
two years that she lives the money will
be earning a decent rate of return
i mean we're not talking about a lot of
money here we're talking about the
difference in nothing and about 30 000
a year so basically if this money were
invested
it would make enough to cover the
difference
that she doesn't have or pretty close
and so you wouldn't burn through it you
would basically sit there and tread
water
and the whole 300 give or take a little
bit
depending on how she lives and how the
market does and all that kind of thing
would be there for the heirs that's how
i personally would want to handle it
if i were in her shoes but i'm very
comfortable with all of that and i would
not want her to do that
if it kept her awake at night if she
were scared
we're certainly not going to make
investment decisions based on a
banker's recommendation that's like
making a transmission decision based on
a
muffler guy's recommendation you don't
need to do that
so you need to sit down with an
investing professional
and if she's cognitive talk to her about
what she wants to do with her money
mom do you want to want the money to
work a little harder and take a little
risk with it
or do you want to park over here and not
make much but have no risk
that's really her two options there's
not much middle ground
it's really going to be a little bit one
way or the other but the risk is not
it's that she's going to lose it all
because that doesn't happen
good question side note
you ever hear some people say i lost all
of my retirement money in the stock
market
you heard somebody say that
that is someone that did one of two
things they either
emotionally were so caught up in the
market going down
that they just lied
because there's never been a time that
the stock market even in the great
depression even the crash of 29
or the dad blame rock slide of 2008
whatever you want to call it right
the market went in half
and so if you had a million dollars at
the beginning of the 2008 slide
it would have become worth a half a
million dollars
and today it would be worth four million
dollars if you left it alone
okay so if you bought at the highest
possible point but
before the 2008 slide and you sold at
the lowest possible point
and you had a million dollars you would
have lost a half million dollars that
would feel that would leave an ouchy
mark
that would feel like crap like oh no i
just lost a half million dollars ouch
and if you cashed out you would have
locked that loss in and you would have
lost
that money but you still cannot say i
lost all my money in the stock market
because you didn't you could say i lost
half my money in the stock market that
would be accurate
point being that even when you're 90 if
the market goes down
unprecedented with the exception of a
couple of times in a hundred years
if the market went down fifteen percent
oh
god it's sixty thousand dollars out of
three hundred
k and it comes back
so far a hundred percent of the time
so far there's no guarantee
there's no guarantee about that house
you bought either
oh well real estate's a good investment
i'm trusted
well why why do you trust it
because your whole life you've been
driving by houses and
especially if you're old like me you've
been watching these houses go up in
value for a long time i turned 18 years
old i sold my first house for forty two
thousand five hundred dollars
i got my real estate license three weeks
before that
which tells you a couple things number
one an 18 year old kid sold a house
number two somebody was dumb enough to
buy from him
and number three they bought a house in
1978 for 42
500 which today would be easily worth
over 300.
now we all kind of know that if we got
walking around since so we feel
comfortable with stuff
with real estate investing but the stock
market is exactly the same way what are
we looking at there we're looking at
historical data
we're looking at the period of time over
which real estate has gone up in value
and it's gone up in value pretty well
all the time
stock market exactly the same way but
there's something different about the
stock market i guess because you don't
drive by it and you don't see the trees
in the bushes
and the bricks and the mortar and so
there's something emotional feels out of
control about it
but if you're looking at historical data
well past performance is not indicative
of future performance yes it is
it's the only thing you've got to
forecast with that's the biggest line of
crap ever put out by a regulator
they have to put these big disclaimers
on the bottom of all investments past
performance is not indicative of future
yes it is it's the only thing that is i
mean
my past performance of growing hair on
top of my head is indicative of the
future of that
it's not likely to cause start happening
tomorrow
you know it's not going to happen it's
it's you can
take the past and project it into the
future it is going to
happen most of the time unless something
changes so
that's what you're looking at when
you're looking at stock market history
when you're looking at real estate
history you look back far enough to go
is this a stable investment
it's why i don't invest in other things
because when i look at the history
it's too scary for me and there is the
chance of losing
100 of your money that's why i don't
invest in currencies
that's why all the bitcoin people are
angry with me
because i'm not jumping in on their
little fad uh
it's you know i got socks older than
bitcoin
and i'm just i'm sorry guys you can be
angry with me and you can call me
unsophisticated and do doesn't know what
he's doing
none of which would be true except you
just disagree with me and i hurt your
little feelings
and you've made some money on bitcoin
lately i'm glad you made money i didn't
want you to lose money i want everybody
to prosper
but i don't like the risk i don't like
the risk i don't buy gold because i
don't like the risk
the volatility of gold is cray-cray it's
nutty
so what you're looking at when you
invest 300 thousand dollars
you're not going to lose 300 000
if you put it in mutual funds now if you
put in a single stock that company could
go broke and you could lose the
entire thing on that one company but
that would be
ludicrous but if you're well diversified
the chances of you losing it all are
very close to zero
the chances of you losing half of it are
very close to zero
so you can't go i lost all my retirement
no you didn't
stop your trauma queening this
is the ramsey shack
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes
you are the next greatest generation
because you
have proven that even in adversity that
you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance career training
and a paycheck to help you avoid debt no
matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
cynthia is in new orleans welcome to the
ramsey show cynthia how can i help
hi thank you for taking my call i have a
question i'm retired i'm 60
and i had to go back to work and the job
that i have now
does not uh put into retirement so
i talked to a small investor pros she
suggested that that i don't
worry about investing into retirement
at this point and just focus on paying
off my home
do you agree with that not a bad idea
how much do you have in retirement
i only have like a hundred thousand okay
all right uh and what are you making uh
at your new job now that you're retired
about 3 000 a month and what is your uh
do you have
a retirement income already coming in
from your old job or from social or
anything yeah
yes 2500 a month 2500
okay all right good well how much do you
owe on your home
about um
to 220.
[Music]
i think that's probably pretty good
advice um i'd love for you to be doing
both you don't have a ton of money
coming in
um you've you've got about 60 000 coming
in total between these two or three
sources
and so um i'd love you to get that house
knocked out
uh because a paid for house sets you up
for a lot of stability
in your latest years you know like when
you're 80 with a paid for house versus a
mortgage that's a big deal
okay it would be okay if you wanted to
do a roth ira
i mean you can do six seven thousand
dollars a year on that
um that's not going to keep you from
paying off the house
um if you want to go that route that
would be okay
uh it's not the end of the world i mean
you qualify to do seven thousand a year
at age
since you're over 50 and you're making
over there you have the earned income so
you could do a roth if
if you want to but over five years it's
just 35
000 you're putting in and it only
reduces how much you pay on your
mortgage by 35 000
so um you know yeah i might go ahead and
do a roth just to get some more going in
there but
but i really do want you to focus
everything you can focus on the majority
of it
on paying off the house so i think the
the essence of what your smartvestor pro
told you i would completely agree with
so hey thank you for the call and
congratulations on the retirement
andrew is with us andrew's in atlanta hi
andrew what's up
hi dave pleasure to speak with you sure
15 months ago i entered into a
three-year car lease
since then i've learned how foolish that
was and i'm considering how to get out
of it
given the current market and the car's
value should i find a way out or you
know specifically
would the dealership let somebody come
back in and just say i want out you guys
can make
more on it right now um
or should i just take the lesson learned
and never lease again when it's over
well the way the numbers work out is
this what you're on the hook
for is 20 more months approximately of
your car payment
plus the er plus the closed in buyout at
the end there's a stated value in your
in your fleece that you can buy the car
for at the end of the 36 months
there's approximately 20 months of that
left right 30
30 000 plus about uh is 800
car payments so uh it's a monster it's
about 46 000 yen nice car ridiculous big
car
yeah okay um and
um so those are the two numbers you can
add those two numbers together
and say that's what the whole picture
looks like now if you wanted to get out
the way to measure against it is really
to measure the 800
per month for 30 months or for i'm sorry
there's 20
months left so um is that 16
000 is that right no is it 160 14 600
14 600 or something around there yeah
yeah
am i dropping a zero uh but anyway the
uh
uh so compare what you have
exposure that you have yeah it'd be 14
000 uh 16 000 somewhere in there
um versus what you would lose on it if
you sold it today
now the way you would calculate that is
you find out what you can sell it for in
this ridiculous wonderful hot market for
used cars
and you compare that to another number
and that's calling the
fleece who have you got the fleece with
you call toyota and say i want the early
buyout number which is the equivalent of
your payoff today
that's not the 30 000 at the end that's
today if i write a check today and pay
the thing off
that compared to the value how far
upside down are
you less i'm sorry that could be less
than
what the less than 15 000.
and so you know uh what was the original
msrp on the car the sticker price
uh i was looking at the lease here the
uh adjusted capital cost is 55
i don't i don't know what the sticker
price was again i learned the hard way
that's okay
all right and uh have you looked up what
it's worth at all
um the trade-in value is around 43 uh
private parties around 46. okay so let's
call it 45 for discussion purposes
and now you call toyota up and they say
um your early buyout is uh
40. okay you can write a check today for
40 and be clear
then that means you're five in the hole
if you keep it you're 15 in the hole
even if you turn it in
right yeah so if you want out of it this
is probably going to be a good one to
get out of
you're probably going to find you're not
much in the hole right now what is what
kind of toy
must be a truck yeah it's a time drill
yeah
it's a beast double cab so what i did
going through the specifics would i find
someone that is willing to buy it from
me
and then yeah you would sell the car to
someone
and write a check for the difference in
that and the early buyout
and you've got to send that whole amount
to toyota then they send you a title
okay so i just let toyota know i'm
selling it and i'm
yeah i'm sorry i hadn't looked up any
details i'm just curious about how that
yeah
well i mean the way you left it's just
like pretend you had a car loan
uh god forbid with bank of america the
title would not be held at your local
branch it'd be held out of town
yeah and so if you did the same thing
and you were upside down there you have
to give the whole amount of the payoff
which is the amount you put with it plus
what the buyer gives you right so the
buyer drives off with a car
and a bill of sale and the keys that's
the way it always works
then you send the full payoff to bank of
america in this case toyota
they send you the title you sign it over
to your buyer it takes about five weeks
okay four weeks three weeks depending on
how efficient toyota
is uh to get you know to get the full
transaction done
now and if you do it with a dealer
you're going to get less for it because
the dealer is going to buy it at
wholesale
but you're not going to have to screw
with anything they're going to take care
of everything so i'd get a dealer bid on
it
see what a toyota dealer will give you
i'd compare that to what private sale is
saying on
kelly blue book and then i'd get your
early buyout number
from toyota but you're going to write a
check for something here
it's just not going to be as much as if
you keep it
understood thank you hey thanks for the
call man i appreciate you joining us
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two
five you jump in we'll talk about your
life and your money the car
fleece is the most
expensive way to operate an automobile
it is not cheaper
it's more
because when you add up the numbers he
just said
and here's the thing that car goes in
his example he
msrp sticker was 55 at the time he turns
it back in three years later
the turn in value is 30 000 he can buy
the car for 30 000 at that time or hand
them the keys
right now i'll guarantee you this
toyota's a lot of things but stupid's
not on the list
100 of the time that 30 000 has been
very carefully calculated with toyota
tundra statistical evidence that says
that that's about what that car is going
to be worth he's it's not a 35
000 car and he can buy it for 30 at the
end of the lease
and it's not a 40 000 car that he can
buy for 30 at the end of the lease
and it's not a 28 thousand dollar car
that he can buy for 30th and lease it's
a 30 000
car you could buy for 30. so when you
put that number in there with 800 and
some dollars a month you figure out what
his
cost of capital is which is the
effective interest rate
and it generally is around 14.2 percent
it's the most expensive way to buy a
stinking car
don't do it it's a car fleece
you're getting fleeced it's a bad idea
[Music]
paying off debt is smart saving
and investing is smart being generous is
smart
but there's one key to winning with
money that's often forgotten and that's
protecting
your family from emergencies there are
ten kinds of insurance coverage you
might
need based on what stage of life you're
in and we've built a tool to show you
what coverage
you need to add which one of the
rip-offs you need to drop
or what you need to adjust it only takes
five minutes and it's free we'll even
rank
your to-do list by importance email it
to you so you've got a game plan you're
ready to go fast
it's free it's called the coverage
checkup and it could be the most
important five minutes that you spend
today
one of our listeners named donald wrote
and said uh for anyone who's not
completed this checkup do it right now
you never know
when something will happen and you never
want to leave your family in a bad
situation
sounds like he knows personally i'm
afraid text
check up to 33 789 it's free
text check up two three three
seven eight nine don't let an emergency
sneak up on you
defense is as important as offense
in finance carla is with us carla
is in des moines iowa hi carla welcome
to the ramsey show
hi dave thanks for taking my call
i we have four rental properties and
we're just wondering if you have any
like
baby steps associated with owning
the rental properties like you do with
uh like on your personal side you know
the
is there a certain amount we should have
an emergency fund and
and like where do we park extra money
as we're saving to buy the next one
okay are they all paid for um we have
kind of a little bit of a long story we
have like a three thousand dollars on
one
because our personal residence is
will be a hundred years old next year
and people
our age are getting older and they have
things like hip replacements and that so
we're thinking
we're gonna probably have to get out of
this place eventually and so
we we keep a little bit of a note there
at the bank so we have that relationship
um with them in case we do you want a
relationship with a bank
so we can borrow when we need to get our
own like if we need to get a different
house like we don't need to move right
now yeah so what's the house that you're
living in worth it's worth maybe
95 000. and when you sell it and buy the
one that you want to live in because you
can't live in it anymore because of hip
replacements what would you buy
well we'd probably buy a ranch thing so
it's all one level
i don't know around that but there's
that period of time where you have to
get
like the loan no you don't you know you
put your house up for sale and you sell
it on a contingency and you go buy it
you've done enough real estate deals you
know that and all of your rentals paid
for except for three thousand dollars
yeah yeah okay write a check today and
pay off the stupid loan
okay that's your baby step then next
baby step is just pile up cash
oh by the way before you get ready to
move you're probably gonna have a big
enough pile of cash to just
buy you a house then when you sell the
one you're living in
you'll be able to use that to buy some
other rentals
so like do you have like like here
we would probably not have to replace
all the water heaters
at the same time the chances of that
happening are very rare but
it would it could happen that we would
have a hail storm and we're replacing
like fighting and you'd have insurance
so like so you just
there's not like an amount that you keep
what does it take to operate the rentals
i try to keep six months of that
of what it takes to operate them just
stay in a cash position real estate
people like me and you are
the world's worst about keeping cash
around we always want to put it back
into more real estate we don't ever have
quite enough cash
well i and that's another question i
have is it possible to have too many
savings accounts um there's no point in
it
one will do the same thing as seven i
know but like if i
if like our car fund if i would marry
that to
our tax fund it looks like i have a
bigger amount
well as long as you keep up with as long
as you keep a little spreadsheet tells
you what the breakdown is it doesn't
matter i know but i have
i how many savings account have you got
well we have we have an hsa and we have
a car fund
and then we have like a taxes fund
and then we have like a a regular
savings account so that um
like it's attached to the checking
account in case i'd ever overdraw the
account which
never happens and then we have like
we have a savings account for our rental
deposits
and then we have like a savings account
for
just rentals in general
well that would be an investment account
the last one should be invested because
your
rentals in general means you're trying
to buy more or in maybe this case you're
going to buy a
personal residence when you sell the one
you're living in for some reason or
another
you're doing fine i i think you're just
obsessing about this whole thing
if you want to have 14 accounts i don't
care it's just a lot of trouble
um but it's also a lot of trouble to
keep up with all of them on a
spreadsheet and they're all in one
so however you want to run it i i don't
keep that many accounts and i got a lot
more rentals than you got
so um i mean i have one account for each
of the businesses that own the rentals
and i've got llcs
that own rentals and when i've got more
than five million dollars in one
llc i open another one and so if i buy a
property that's in excess of 5 million
dollars i have a unique llc just for
that particular property
and so i've got a handful of those but
uh
but that's you know but i don't have
different personal
savings accounts floating around i do
have a separate emergency fund that i
never touch
uh because sharon said uh if i do she's
gone
and um and then
uh beyond that we've got it we're we're
investing money to get ready to buy the
next piece of real estate so you're
doing fine
overall what you're doing is accurate
you know where your money is you know
what's going on
you're in control you've done a great
job it sounds like you've got a net
worth well in excess of a million
dollars
so way to go you're an everyday
millionaire you're a baby steps
millionaire you've done the stuff
way to go samantha is in colorado
springs hi
samantha how are you hi dave thanks for
taking my call
sure what's up um so
my two debts that i have to pay off
um are the exact same amount so i've
asked some other people their opinions
and everybody seems to differ
so i figured i'd ask you um
what's the amount a heloc i have a heloc
for 50 000.
and then i have 50 000 on my student
loans and what's your household income
um we bring in around 6 000 a month
okay your your heloc does not go in baby
step
two it goes in baby step six and it's
big enough you probably need to look at
refinancing your house
and rolling your heloc into a new first
mortgage
because your household income is only 72
000 a year right
yeah yeah yeah so when your heloc our
second
mortgage is over half your annual income
we throw it to baby step six
and in your case it's so big it's gonna
be so long
before you get it and the student loan
knocked out that you need to probably
get you a new first mortgage
what's the balance on your first
mortgage what's the balance on your
first mortgage today
255. 255. so you owe
300 and 5 000 on your home what's it
worth
um about 415. good
okay yeah i probably what's your
interest rate on your first
um it is 3.65 okay you can beat that
and you can get rid of a heloc so you
now have two reasons to refinance unless
you've got bad credit
i'm gonna go get in touch with churchill
mortgage and try to get a 15-year fix
down around three percent
it's going to save you 0.65 on the first
it's going to get rid of the instability
of that heloc because it's usually a
variable rate and it's indexed based on
the banker's whim
meaning it's not indexed at all they
just decide what the freak they want to
charge you on these things and they
change it periodically
they've been historically low for so
long they've lulled everybody to sleep
but they're dangerous as crap
because a lot of them have a call and
almost all of them have a variable rate
that's not end
indexed to anything anything
so that's simple uh yeah i refinanced
that then that means guess what we're
working on your student loan we're gonna
knock it out as fast as you possibly can
and that means beans and rice rice and
beans extra jobs not eating out you're
not going on vacation until you get rid
of
said sally may that old woman needs her
eviction notice from your life
get after it get it get it you got this
you can do it
that puts us hour the ramsey show in the
books our thanks to james childs our
producer kelly daniel is our associate
producer and phone screener
i'm dave ramsey your host and we will be
back
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as
the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host this is common sense
for your
dollars and cents teaching you to live
on less than you make a concept congress
can't grasp
it's a free call at triple eight eight
two five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five
five two two five cameron is in kansas
city to start this hour off
hi cameron how are you doing well dave
how about yourself
better than i deserve how can i help
i'm just looking for some advice between
the balance in terms of paying off our
mortgage early
and our long-term investment plan
so i'm 29 married with a two-year-old
and another
kid on the way wonderful um
we we currently owe 245 on our house
we put about a hundred thousand down
about a year ago good
um and we have 65k
in cash savings
i make 125 in base and bonus and then my
company does
for an esop so about 11 percent esop
contribution on top of that
okay here's the program that we have
used
to lead tens of thousands of people into
millionaire
into being millionaires having a million
dollar net worth or greater
we call it the baby steps and you may
have heard them baby step one
save a thousand dollars two is be
debt-free with your house you've done
those two
uh three i think you've done those two
you're out of debt except the house
right
correct okay three is having uh three to
six months of expenses set aside for
emergencies
55 000 would qualify as a matter of fact
it's probably a little high
for your emergency fund beyond that we
do
baby steps four five and six
simultaneously
which is to your question and that's 15
of your income going into retirement
which is a substantial amount right now
with
your great income then we start putting
something in baby step 5 towards the
kids college and you can decide how
beefy you want to do that
but i want you with a couple kids be
doing at least 100 bucks a month or
something just get started at least
if you want to get beefier that's fine
beyond that i throw
everything i can get my hands on at the
house now until it's paid off and then
once it's paid off we max out
all retirement that's available and
become very wealthy which is baby step
seven
now why do i do that well number one at
babysit four you're putting 15
of your income away which at 29 years
old is 30 000 bucks
and so you've got millions of dollars at
retirement in that account
if you do nothing else you're going to
be just fine
but you're not going to do nothing else
not with what i just outlined
you're also going to save up and pay
cash for your kids college and baby step
five
and in six we're going to go and get the
house paid off now we've
completed at ramsey research the largest
study of millionaires in north america
ever done
93 of them did not
become millionaires from inherited money
and i can unpack that if you want me to
point being they all did something to
build wealth
what did they do by far the vast
majority of them we found
in almost every time to the point it was
almost stereotypical
in almost every case we found they had
done two things
one is they had significantly and
steadily funded
their 401k roth ira retirement plans
and that like say i found somebody with
a million and a half dollar net worth
that was often times a million dollars
the second thing they had done is they
got their home paid off and that was
often times a half million dollars
so for an everyday or a baby steps
millionaire someone who followed those
baby steps
under a five million dollar net worth
what we typically found was their house
was about a third
of their net worth and it was paid off
that element and the big loaded up
retirement
was uh the two main things we saw over
and over again the point being
cameron that we didn't find hardly
anyone who had a big home mortgage
because they put it all in investments
sure yeah and i think that's really
where my question comes in is
you know basically 11 of my compensation
goes into our esap i'm contributing
eight percent to mine are you putting
eleven percent in
the company contributes eleven percent
i'm asking you to put in fifteen
of your income so i do eight percent to
my roth
i would have you put in 15 of your
household income into retirement
in addition to the 11 you're not putting
in the 11
they are
they're not taking it out of your check
are they yeah so that's
a huge piece of i'm sorry are they
taking it out of your check or are
they giving you money are they putting
it in there
they put it in there okay it's not
coming out of your check so the
incumbent figures you gave me were not
including that correct it would be like
140
so this is like a match in a way
okay yeah better than yeah so you don't
you don't worry about that i mean that's
nice that's gravy on the biscuit
but i want you to take your household
income before
income taxes are taken out and say 0.15
and i want that much going into
retirement that's 15
that's a lot more than you're doing
right now sure
and and even with what i'm doing right
now i mean
the the calculations spit out you know
10
15 million of the future retirement
which then feels somewhat silly to
to still be paying a mortgage right now
so i think that you're not gonna have
both
you're 29. okay you're you're not gonna
you know own only have 10 million
dollars and never pay your mortgage off
because you're going to pay off your
mortgage long before then
even if you hadn't called me you would
have done that but you don't need to
stop
doing retirement because oh i've done
enough and i'm counting on them putting
in 11
no you put in 15 percent and you go
ahead and put the balance that you can
find in your budget without straining
too much and not taking
well you know your wife still gets to
buy a couch you still get to go on a
vacation
uh and you'll find money out of there to
chunk and you'll hit bonuses and stuff
you can chunk towards that house you're
gonna have that house paid off for five
years
even putting 15 of your income away and
you're easily gonna hit
both but no i would not back off and say
oh retirement's handled
no i'm not that's the other direction i
wouldn't go
so i wouldn't uh you're going to be fine
i do think your prediction is accurate
this is not discussing whether you're
going to be bankrupt or not you're
you're doing a great job a you're paying
attention you're being very intentional
with your decision making you're
thinking about this you're good using
good critical thinking skills so
you're not going to make a big mistake
but if you were following our plan which
is what i would
tell you to do because it's called our
plan um
you know it'd be 15 of your income into
retirement and then kids college
and then getting your home paid off
so
here's what's interesting about
cameron's call
and about what some of you are thinking
while you're riding around listening to
the show right now
you're thinking that sounds so simple
you know why because it is
it's very simple to understand what to
do
the problem comes
in the doing it oh there's the problem
you know you lose weight take in less
calories
that's a problem though this boy likes
chocolate doughnuts
they're in danger if i'm near i know
what to do
the problem comes in the doing it
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special savings
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well the housing market's a bit hot
isn't it
talked to a guy who put his home on the
market over the weekend
87 people looked at the house
he has 17 offers in 24 hours all of them
over asking price
some poor guy who bid 50 000 over asking
price
16 of them are not going to get the
house
that's a hot market wow and
is this going to continue at this rate
probably not
there are several leading indicators in
the market that the
rate of housing price climb
inflation is going to slow
lumber has finally caught up and has uh
has no longer spiking in price with a
new record every month
new housing is starting to catch up in a
lot of areas so
the market's not going to reverse itself
and it's not going to collapse in on
itself or something like that but
we're going to continue to see prices
increasing it's going to be as hot as
it's been
now here's the trick you do need to
those of you keeping your homes and not
selling in this crazy market
you do need to check your homeowners
insurance
because it has a stated value on it
uh it does not cover what the house is
worth it covers what the policy says
and so if your policy hasn't been
updated in a year
your house could be worth hundreds of
thousands of dollars more than it was at
this time last year and you're not
covered
so you need to make sure that's done and
you could get
even while you're at it you ought to
price your homeowners insurance because
you're probably paying too much the
market has really shifted on that
so our endorsed local providers for
insurance
are independent agents which means they
shop a gazillion different companies and
get you the best possible deal
so what you do is you text home to 33 17
33 789 text home
to three three seven eight nine and
you'll talk with a trusted
insurance pro a ramsey trusted insurance
pro about finding the right coverage for
you
they're gonna shop a bunch of people get
you the best deal oh and make sure your
home is properly
covered it used to adjust based on
market value
but those were old policies and they're
just about all gone now
you have a stated coverage amount and
that's all you got plus or minus a
little of an inflation factor but you're
not covered if you haven't kept yours up
to date
text home 233
789 gary's in charleston south carolina
hey gary welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
uh well my wife christy and i are here
um and
we've we sold our boat that was our paid
off boat
and our paid off truck in this market we
got top dollar
and we're using that plus a little bit
of savings
uh to pay off the house tomorrow yay way
to go
yeah thanks so uh you know we've
you know we've kind of worked hard and
uh you know
increased our income to where it's at
today and paid off all the bills and
congratulations that people anyway
thank you but uh but yeah we started
watching your show
and now we've you know consolidated all
our bills together
uh you know which made us waste less
money but now we're at that point
uh we're hitting baby step seven um
and next steps and yeah we just
we have more money than we know to do
with what do you mean what's your
household income
household income this year should be
right at 360.
wow how old are you guys
i'm 38 she's 40. yay and what's the
house worth
um 325 to 350.
excellent how much is in your retirement
accounts your nest egg
uh selective collectively around
360. okay all right cool we but we maxed
them out and we maxed them out
uh each year she she started sooner than
i did and i know
i started recently well you guys are
doing a great job
i mean in about 20 seconds you're going
to be millionaires and you're on your
way well done
what can i answer for you uh well
yeah we we we have some money in stocks
have about
you know six figures in stock still and
now we're about to have a lot of
disposable income
and while i haven't been wrong on my
individual stock
that i've been investing in uh i know
that you teach to diversify and i think
that's a
you know a very wise move and i'd like
to go that way
moving forward okay um so uh
just some of your suggestions of now
we're gonna have a disposable income
anywhere between seven seventy five
hundred and nine thousand a month
so what do we do with it excellent well
such choices to have
yeah it's such a problem
well it goes back to philosophically or
theologically there's only three things
you can do with money
you can be generous with it and you
should so label some of it for
generosity
you can invest it and you should
so label some of it for that and you can
enjoy it
and you should so label some of it for
that
uh and and so there are some items out
there in your future
that two years ago would have been
immature and silly
but two years from today you'll be able
to purchase that item and pay cash for
it and it will fit right in
and you won't have to worry about it
it's a non-issue because it's a small
enough
as a percentage of your wonderful world
that you'll be able to do
that thing go on that trip buy that
classic car
buy that piece of jewelry that piece of
art i don't know something that you
enjoy
then you're going to invest now i only
invest in two things
i invest in real estate that i pay cash
for
and i invest in good growth stock mutual
funds spreading across the four types
i'm a little heavier in real estate than
i am in mutual funds for two reasons
one is i bought about um about several
about about 100 million dollars worth
back in 2008
and i bought it at about 10 cents on the
dollar about 50 million dollars worth
actually so
it ended up shooting way up because i
bought it way at the bottom i haven't
been able to buy anything like that
since but um
so i love real estate but i'm heavy in
real estate for that reason because my
returns have been better there
because i bought at the worst time in
the last 40 years
probably uh and so which is to my
advantage
so anyway you're buying real estate that
i pay cash for and then investing in
mutual funds
and whichever one you're more
comfortable with some people don't like
mutual funds so they're light in those
some don't want to deal with tenants and
the hassles of
owning real estate and so they don't
have any or hardly any in real estate
um you know if you have something else
you want to play in that's fine if you
want to buy a little bit of single
stocks i don't suggest you have more
than
10 percent of your net worth in your
case that'd be a
you know less than a hundred thousand
dollars in single stocks because it's
just too risky
but if you really have a thing for it
and you want to put that much in there
and play with it you'll be okay you're
not going to mess it up doing that
because you've got a small enough amount
in there that even if you lost the whole
thing which you would never do
that but even if you lost the whole
thing you still would be worth over a
million dollars in just a few minutes
here
so all of that to say congratulations
the trick is now
take that disposable income and just
label it
x for fun y for investing
and z for generosity and um
then you're going to be very intentional
about your investing very intentional
about your fun
and very intentional about your
generosity within that set amount of
dollars
and so that allows sharon and i to do
some really fun things
uh with the amount of wealth that we've
built and we don't even have to
uh emotionally sweat it oh are we
are we bad christians if we buy that no
we've been very intentional good
stewards
and it's a small percentage of our world
and then when we get ready to do some
generosity we're like oh have we messed
up our whole estate plan because we gave
too much away
no we're not being crazy we're being
very wise and yet outrageously
generous but when that money's already
earmarked to give away
and you set it aside it's interesting
your emotions have already given it away
you just haven't transferred the bank
account yet
and so go ahead and do some of that when
we move our money into our family
foundation
it's already given away technically
speaking it's already given away in that
case because it's a foundation but
also emotionally we were done with it
once we earmarked
that money going that direction and it
just gives you a lot of peace
that all three things are happening the
way they should fun
generosity and investing to create more
fun
and more generosity
[Music]
[Music]
gravy
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage
josh and ali are with us hey guys how
are you
good how are you sporting some
good-looking t-shirts
straight out of debt baby i like it
congratulations how much have you paid
off
we paid off 31 03.45
great how long did it take four months
and five days wow
and your range of income during that
time uh 90k to 95. we didn't really get
a raise we just had a
couple of stimulus and we sold stuff
okay that's a stimulus too excellent
yay love it love it love it that sounds
fun way to go you guys what kind of debt
was the 31 000
uh we had two cars uh student loans a
couple of credit cards and some medical
bills so
normal kind of normal yeah how long you
all been married
since november 2nd so not too too long
that's kind of why we went on the
journey together to be honest
gotcha okay so as soon as you get
married boom game on knock this out
or right before you got married you
started it tell me exactly what happened
here so we got
married in october and started on the
12th of november
just like that just like that so i'm a
mortgage loan officer so i kind of
talk about the debt snowball a lot
believe it or not so it's one of those
things i was like you know we should
probably look into this you know if we
want to have the life that we really
want together you know that we vowed to
each other then we need to kind of
do something about it okay so
um what what how did you decide how did
you have this discussion before you
while you're being engaged and actually
when
after we got married we had cash flowed
our wedding without knowing that that's
what we were doing
um and it was weird because when we were
able to pay
cash for the wedding we were like what
have we been doing with we could have
been
saving money this whole time how did we
do that so
he brought it up to me after we got
married like hey maybe we should pay off
all our debt you know maybe that's the
next
best thing we can do in order to start
saving for since i talk about this to
other people all the time
okay yeah it's easy to talk about you
know other people's
debt and other people's problems and not
necessarily look at your own and i
actually grew up listening to you but
in my mind like you know as a child a
lot is caught and
what i caught from that was that dave
ramsey was for people that had their
lives together so we never really
we never really did that because our
lives weren't really together
yeah that's funny when quite the
opposite is true but yeah
[Laughter]
that's so fun all right so it just kind
of came together gelled and you said oh
i had this
epiphany we pay cash for the wedding we
can do this i tell people to do this
we can do it um and game on yeah so just
like that you joined arms and went after
it
yeah and i kind of suggested to him
after he brought it up he's like we
should pay off debt and i was like
you know what we could do we could sell
a car oh
and he went oh well i don't know oh
could this be my car that would be the
one that gets sold
so naturally yeah that's the way to
start the honeymoon yeah
we did it um we sold the car yeah that's
how we started
what was it what kind of car it was a
2015 kia optima
oh nice car gone okay what are you
driving now
2019 kia forte oh my god that's not
exactly a
big like you're not dying no not at all
oh man and it's paid for it
and it's faithful so that's a that's
enough of a move to get the get the goal
hit
yeah and now you're free and you can do
whatever you want with this kind of
income and no payments
how's that feel to knock that out that
fast as your first order of business in
a marriage
so when we first started like we kind of
did we did the budget you know we did
the
every dollar app and everything and we
were like okay we should be able to do
this in about seven months
and then at that point we weren't even
tithing
so we were like okay seven months no
tithing you know we should be able to do
this and then
we just kind of decided like you know we
should really you know
be thankful for like the position we're
in the jobs that we have and so we
started tithing
and lo and behold we actually did it in
four and a half months it was
with tithing so we were like oh wow you
know this is
you know we listen to you a lot and a
lot of people
go through it like they think that this
is going to be a long process and it
doesn't have to be if you are a gazelle
intense like you say to people
you know you don't have to spend 200 on
groceries you know you
if you budget everything and you can
make the make it work however you want
sell stuff you know
there's so many different ways to become
debt free and you know the
the weight that it's lifted off of us is
just unbelievable
the interesting thing is you get to
decide how hot to turn the flame
no one just i didn't call you up and go
turn it up hotter
right you know you just decide i want to
get out faster i'm going to turn it up a
little hotter
or i don't really think i'm going to do
that i'm going to turn it back a little
bit you get to decide it's your flame
it's your
how much do you want to cut how far how
deeply do you want to cut into this
budget and you're in control
it's not like dave ramsey's going to
come knock on your door and check your
budget
and what's funny about that is you start
off thinking that there are things that
you need to do that you have to have
and then as you get closer and you see
your progress you know with the snowball
you you start to realize that there are
things you can live without you can make
deeper cuts and sacrifice to get there
faster and and race against yourself so
yeah that's it it becomes kind of a
little mental
emotional game doesn't it yeah and for
sure there's a lot of times where
we didn't spend all our money on
groceries that we had budget for our
groceries and it went straight to debt
and then
allie was like oh you know we can
probably cut back on groceries we have
enough left over from the week before
and then you know then you start
becoming so obsessed
with paying off the day i'm a huge nerd
i didn't know that before but i'm the
nerd
i love it dial it spreadsheet up dial
that every dollar
i like it very good that's cool yeah we
start redefining
uh correctly what most people in america
including you including me have defined
incorrectly and that is the difference
in wanting a need
most of us have absolutely no needs in
this country there's very few people
actually have a need
most of stuff we call i need is i want
most the time and then you go i found
out i didn't have to have that to live
you know
and i didn't have to have that to live
and look at that and we can get a little
faster and
then when we're free we can do a lot
more we can live like no one else and
and give like no one else so what do you
tell people when they ask you that the
key to doing this is
i always say the key is just having be
consistent with it and
don't fall into the stigma that debt is
normal right like i've seen i see credit
reports every day and people have all
these car
payments and for the longest time myself
i thought you're gonna have a car
payment until you die
right that's just a normal thing that
people think cars break down
just don't fall into that stigma your
debt is not good
and it's one of those things it's not a
tool to use
for things you know you just pay it off
you you don't realize the weight that
can be lifted until it's gone yeah
and it feels it feels clean now doesn't
it yeah simple right you're just
swimming in a bad pool to a good pool
i would just add also the budget because
i thought that i
we thought that we were budgeting before
and
we would go where where where is all
this money we should have where did it
go
we didn't have an answer for it so being
very diligent about that budget
that was a bad word in my family growing
up sure
it led to money fights and so i think i
kind of avoided that
um but it now budget's fun for us right
yeah it's like oh we can
like cash flow vacation in two months
you know what i mean
all this money right and who can we help
with it and all kinds of stuff it
changes everything
well way to go very very cool and isn't
it interesting
that you you made you're giving a full
10
to your local church and didn't slow you
down but sped you up
yeah it was oxymoronic it is that was
honestly like
my five-man honda that was the hardest
part for me was getting my heart right
because i knew that i was being called
to do that that we were being called to
do that
and it i was selfish but your mat well
your math brain says that's backwards
yes right
you want me to give money away but i'm
gonna get out of that faster that just
seems backwards well that wasn't even
the reason that we did it we just felt
that that was what we're supposed to do
we felt led to do it and
and it was like god was saying hey look
i i got something better for you
like just let me let me help you because
i can do this faster than you think you
can
so and then we fully funded our
emergency fund two months after paying
off debt
wow so you guys are so impressive well
done
well we got a copy of the legacy journey
for you that's your next step is to
completely change your whole legacy and
you are well on your way you got a great
start
so proud of you another copy of total
money makeover for you to give away to
somebody get their journey started
you can pay it forward with that as well
and of course that's our our number one
best seller by far around here
so congratulations we're very proud of
you thank you very proud of you too you
guys are impressive
all right it's josh and ali murphysboro
tennessee
31 000 paid off
the first order of business and four
months of marriage make a 90 to 95
game on count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
three two one
ah love it
man that's powerful well done you two
very well done
[Music]
[Music]
it is oxymoronic to think that
generosity
adds to prosperity
you would think if i had a bigger pile
of money because i hadn't given some
away that i would be more prosperous
and the truth is the opposite happens
and it happens so often
that it is a principle now for those of
us that are people of faith
evangelical christians we're taught and
believe that the bible says
that we're to give a tenth of our income
to our local church
a tenth a tithe which is a hebrew word
obviously an old english word
representing a hebrew word
but it literally the word means tenth
one tenth of our income
now you may or may not agree with that
that's not up for discussion you can
agree with it and if you do that's fine
if you don't then i get to do it it's my
faith i get to choose you get to choose
what you do
i'm not telling you you have to do
something but that's what
my faith teaches as an evangelical
christian
and here's the interesting thing about
that the bible says in malachi a
testimony in this
says the lord of hosts god says test me
talking about the tithe he's discussing
the tithe right before that
regarding the tithe test me god says
test me
and see if i will not throw open the
windows of heaven
and pour out for you a blessing
that you cannot contain
and i will rebuke the devourer
for your sakes now the word blessing
there does not mean bmw in the hebrew
it is not necessarily the word blessing
is not
necessarily money or wealth
now sometimes people on the prosperity
side of the christian world
quote that scripture and says god
promises to bless you financially if you
tithe
that's not what the word says the word
is the word barakah b-e-r-k-a-h
and if you look it up in the strong's
concordance which is where you get an
english translation
of the hebrew word you'll find that word
b-e-r-k-a-h
means peace refreshment
as a camel finds
in an oasis at an oasis there's always
shade
there's always water
as opposed to a dry parched desert
now reread that test mean this says the
lord of hosts and see if i will not
throw open for you
the windows of heaven and pour out for
you a blessing
that you cannot contain peace
as a camel finds at an oasis
that you cannot contain now what ends up
happening
whether you're a person of faith or not
here's the principle that works
and it works again you don't there's no
it's not unique
to christianity although it manifests
itself well within the
christian theology what happens is this
it's almost impossible to be a miserable
person when you are a generous person
generous people are almost always
happier
a lower incidence of depression among
generous people
very few people that are generous are
depressed
it's very unusual almost never happens
generous people are attractive
they smile more they're not attractive
because people want to be around them to
get money from them that's not the point
the point is the generosity is not just
an
act it is a character quality that
induces several acts like
integrity integrity is not an act
you have integrity you are a person of
integrity
you are a generous person it is a
character quality like honesty integrity
kindness it's something now if you're a
kind person that's the quality
when you when you out of your kindness
you do something if you're a
compassionate person
that's the quality out of that you're
compassionate to someone
then that's the verb that comes out of
your character quality
and i think we can all agree joyful
people
generous people compassionate people
kind people
are all more attractive oh couldn't we
use a little more of that
attractiveness in our culture today
there's a lot of just ugliness
out there today and most of it is born
in fear
which is not attractive most of it is
born in
anger which is not attractive most of it
is born in selfishness
versus selflessness which is not
attractive
so here's what ends up actually
happening the people who
have as a steady part of their financial
diet
the rhythm of their life they are
generous
people who tithe their weekly paycheck
to their local church
people who give regularly not just
once a year not randomly but as a part
of the rhythm of your life like
breathing and bathing you're giving
you're catching somebody at the gas pump
and you just buy their gas
you buy the person behind you at the
starbucks lines next order
i don't care what it is those are little
tiny things maybe you do some nice big
things maybe
you pay for an orphanage to be built
maybe you pay for a hospital to be built
i don't care how many zeros there are on
it
but when people have a regular rhythm of
generosity they are a different kind of
a person
and they're very attractive and people
want to be around them and they want to
have them
as employees and they want to work
for people like that as an employer
they are easier to work business deals
with
they're not functioning in fear and
anger all the time
there's a little different sense of
confidence and competence
and you know what all of that leads to
more money generous people have a
tendency to prosper
because of that it's not really because
they gave the money away
it's because their heart and who they
were as a person was changed
when they gave the money away and it
made them attractive and attractive
people have more of a tendency to
prosper
than unattractive people i mean think
about it if you're an employer and
you're sitting there and you're looking
at two candidates
that are up for promotion one of them is
going to get the job one isn't
one of them is miserable angry fearful
all the time every time you look at them
they look like they were weaned on a
pickle
and you look at the other one and
they're smiling and they hold the door
open and they always put others
first and they're thinking about how
they can make everything better
instead of how they can make themselves
better and bigger
they're equal in their talents
but that one character quality
distinguishes the two of them apart who
gets the promotion everybody answer with
me the generous person
that's who gets the promotion generous
people have a tendency to prosper
who are you gonna hire to do your lawn
care
who you're gonna hire to fix your car
who are you gonna hire to do your hair
who you're gonna hire to someone's
weaning on a pickle
someone's angry all the time and selfish
and they're figuring how they can cut
every corner on you
or someone's got a little margin in
their life there's a little wiggle room
in their spirit everything's not so
freaking tight
they're not about to explode all the
time
now tell me generous people don't
prosper i've watched it for decades
and this is why you will hear regularly
a testimony and it's not a
mystical weird christian thing but
you'll hear a couple like that last
couple doing their debt-free scream that
says
you know we started giving away 10 of
our income because we thought we
should we were convicted of that
by god's spirit we thought god was
telling us to do that that's exactly
what you heard them say
and yet they got out of debt three
months faster than their original plan
in almost half the time of their
original plan
did the math really change no their
income went up only a little bit they
were able to sell his car
but what changed was them
be not conformed to this world
don't be normal normal sucks
you don't want to be normal don't be
like this world
be transformed how you transformed
the renewing of your mind you change
your mind you get information you didn't
have and you install it into your hard
drive
and the operating system is permanently
changed
it's called living like no one else so
that later you can live and
give like no one else
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show
if you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsyshow.com and register
we would love for you to come to
nashville and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king
and the paid off home mortgage has taken
the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host thank you for
joining us flying solo today here on the
ramsey show
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five emily starts off this hour
in auburn alabama
hi emily how are you good how are you
doing
better than i deserve what's up
a huge fan first of all um so i'll get
right to it
so my husband and i are closing on a
house in a couple of months we
did a sending custom build luckily we
went and right at the same the right
time before all the
cost of lumber went up good um yeah so
we have about 200 000
in savings in the bank 30 000 of that's
going to be our emergency fund
and we're reserving about 20 000 for
housing such as like
fence and any extra furniture that we
need should we put the remaining
all the remaining 150 as a down payment
or
put some of that in another investment
because we're doing the 15 of our income
into retirement
we follow your plan to a t so we just
didn't know if we wanted
all of that money in the house or if we
should put it somewhere else
okay if you follow our plan to a t
and you were already in the house and
above your emergency fund and above your
furniture fund
and above your 15 of your income you
found
some money what would you do with it in
baby step
six i'd pass my house you pay it towards
the house right
right so you wouldn't you wouldn't put
it into an investment because you're
following our plan to a tee
yes and so you're going to put 150 000
down on this house see that's a lot
easier
does that make sense i mean that's just
following the baby steps out
is that life okay yeah i just i asked
you know
i listen to you every day and i just
heard you know well i mean if you call
me up and you had
if you if you put a hundred thousand
down and you put 50 000 mutual funds and
you called me up you said i got 50 000
in mutual funds it's not in retirement
what should i do with it
i would say well you're on baby step six
and i would tell you to pay down the
house
you know that because you follow my plan
to a t right
correct yeah so if you were to invest it
i would have you undo it
so that you could follow our plan to a t
cool
well we will do that then now the reason
is we want to paid for house and the
pile of money in retirement not just one
or the other at the end of the story
right
yes that was correct okay yeah doing so
good well done
appreciate you calling in open phones at
triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five
five two two five well dave ramsey
doesn't know what he's doing
i mean everybody uses a debt that's
wealthy
no you must live in your mother's
basement and write that financial blog
because the actual data of wealthy
people is is that by and large they
don't use debt to get there by and large
they do get their homes paid off
the vast majority of america's
millionaires 93
of them did not inherit their money
according to an airtight piece of
research that the ramsey research team
did
and out of those 93 of america's
millionaires we studied over 10
000 of them the largest study ever done
the vast majority of them paid off their
homes early
and had money in their 401ks and in
their roth iras and mutual funds and
that's how they get their first
1 to 5 million now if you want a billion
instead of for the first five million if
you want to jump
try to straight jump straight to a
billion well you might borrow money out
your eyeballs
that's possible but i'm not here trying
to create billionaires i'm here trying
to create millionaires
because i want families to be able to
retire with dignity be able to change
their family tree and be able to live
well
i don't need you to go broke six times
in the process getting there we're not
trying to write a success manual
on going broke over and over again by
taking all this risk
i went broke once and i did all of i did
that apparently for all of you so you
don't have to
because you can learn from my stupidity
you don't have to follow it
so this is this idea that sophisticated
people all borrow money
is absolute statistical hogwash
it's simply not true they do not
now do sometimes billionaires yes
sometimes they do
does somebody worth 30 million dollars
maybe but you got 30 cents
30 cents and you're losing some of your
cents all the time
and so don't talk to me about how
sophisticated people borrow money you're
freaking broke
they do not now that's what i used to
think
because that's what my broke finance
professor taught me
if your finance professor is broke
that's like
having a shop teacher with missing
fingers
you should think about where you're
getting your advice
so uh be careful when someone says oh
well such and such
like ramsay is not sophisticated the
stuff we teach is
unbelievably profound and sophisticated
it just doesn't line up with your get
rich quick little immature self
and you don't like it some of you oh
well you don't have to follow it
this is america you have the right to be
wrong
you're allowed to go do whatever you
want to do so she's brilliant she's done
a great job they've handled their money
beautifully
and they're well on their way to
substantial wealth
and we meet everyday millionaires baby
steps millionaires who follow these baby
steps by the tens of thousands
every day i meet more
and is it because i didn't make up any
of this i didn't invent any of this
it used to be called common sense
it's just now marketable because it's so
freaking rare
it's like having a superpower
i've made millions and millions of
dollars selling common sense
because there's not any out there and so
it turns out it's like a rare commodity
it's like finding a big old diamond out
in the middle of your backyard
look at that oh my god that's a genius
live on less than you make who would
have thought of that
you know but that's really that's where
we live instead we've got oh i'm gonna
bitcoin my way in and i'm going to play
the lottery
and i'm going to borrow and do nothing
down real estate and buy 73 houses with
no money and think that ain't gonna bite
me in the butt later
of course it's gonna bite you in the
butt later it's gonna take you to your
knees it did me and it will you
please don't do that stuff i'm gonna
bring pain to your family and then you
have to do it all over again
it's much easier just to do it slower
and do it right
it's also faster to do it slower and do
it right
it's easier to do a job right the first
time and wealth building is no different
so walk these baby steps and in 10 to 12
years you'll probably be a millionaire
most of you
but to the extent you don't then you
have to wander off and find your own way
because you're going to reinvent common
sense
that's just silliness and that is not an
indicator that the stuff that the ramsey
personalities and dave ramsey teach is
simplistic
or out of touch or he's such a boomer
oh my god you're such a child
you're just such a baby child listen
little baby child
here's the deal the boomers got this
stuff figured out
that's how i lived this long got this
stinking much money
it didn't cause i was stupid or
unsophisticated
or ignorant or backwoods or any of those
things
this stuff is profound it's easy to
understand but it is life-changing
because you have to change your life to
live like this
in the middle of a culture that's lost
its freaking mind
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to pure talk
they use the same network as the larger
providers for much less
for just 30 a month get unlimited talk
text
and six gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over 70 dollars
a month by switching
to pure top just go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save
50 off your first month pure talk
simply smarter wireless
[Music]
you know what sucks living paycheck to
paycheck
at the end of the month barely covering
the bills and never getting ahead it's
like being stuck in a revolving door
with your money
it doesn't have to be like this you can
stop going in circles and start
making progress check out financial
peace university in
every dollar they're part of ramsey plus
a membership in ramsey plus will show
you how to make the changes you need to
get the results you want with your money
and that's because ramsay plus gives you
complete access to our best online money
courses like i said financial
peace university know yourself know your
money from rachel cruz
all kinds of tools like every dollar all
kinds of stuff there
the ramsey plus membership is everything
you need
you can get out of the cycle you can
start making real progress jump in for
your free trial at rmz plus today
text trial 233
789 text trial 233
789 open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five matt is
in milwaukee
hi matt how are you i'm doing great dave
how are you
better than i deserve what's up
hey i i appreciate everything you do i
just recently got engaged with your
whole program i just got done telling my
wife
all i wanted for father's day was to
enroll in a financial peace course
my question for you is so we work on our
debt snowball now we've got about 135k
in debt mostly student loans cars and a
little bit of credit
uh my question for you is i through my
company have the opportunity to
go through like a employee stock program
at a significant discount
i have been contributing to it yeah
fifteen percent
because of the um so for the stocks they
allow up to about
ten uh should i continue to invest in
that not the performance
the discount is the discount's fifteen
percent in it
yes yes that's standard it's that's
regulatory okay
that's what they all are so my question
oh they are okay i did not know that
um do you recommend continuing to invest
in that based on the discount and
building that up to pay off debt or just
completely putting out all cash stores
i would stop all investing and take any
money that's not in a retirement account
and throw it at your debt snowball
okay and here's why let's look at that
single stock for a second
as i said 15 standard in all employee
stock option plans
if you will pull up your company and
notice i don't even know what it is
and look at your company's stock price
on a 52-week
chart a one-year chart and you will see
the variance
of price most of the time will be in
excess of 15
meaning that um by the time you get it
bought you might have
overpaid for it or you could be buying
it super cheap and it could go up 30
over what you paid for it it's all over
the place it's a
very high risk play playing single
stocks and 15
discount is not enough because the
volatility in one calendar year
generally is going to exceed that
and the volatility was 15 you know we
could talk about the play
but when the discount is 15 the
volatility might be 20 percent
that's not a play you want to make ever
for that matter
but uh if you want to make it you want
to make it on a very small percentage of
your world after you're out of debt
but our the beauty of our get out of
debt thing is matt it's
all about focus and if you'll stop doing
everything else and completely focus on
getting out of debt
and it becomes like a freaking obsession
where you've lost your mind and you get
out of debt
that's how people get out of debt you
can wander into debt but you can't
wander out you can't do six things at
one time
and still get out of debt it won't work
you got to completely
squeeze cash out of everything
stop putting money in anything
until you get the debt paid off and
completely throw it at the debt snowball
that's how people are having these
fabulous stories of getting out of debt
this incredible focused intensity and
that's what you'll learn
in financial peace university and i'll
give it to you for father's day since
your wife didn't we'll
give you a one-year subscription to
ramsey plus which will include financial
peace university the every dollar
premium
and everything else you need to get out
of debt sir we will help you
and you call me back if i can help you
anymore kelly will pick up and she'll
get you signed up and take care of you
anthony's with us in fort myers florida
hi anthony welcome to the ramsey show
hey how's it going um me and my wife
just started
just found you a few months ago and
started following your program
and uh we never had any debt but we just
finished saving
uh six months living expenses right and
it's saving ten thousand dollars
great and um now we're on baby step
three b
saving for a house and i've heard you
say
sometimes keep investing 15
um into retirement and other times put
it on hold
and i was wondering how do you determine
um
whether it would be better to put it on
hold or keep investing 15 while saving
for the house
it's a personal preference some people
prefer to put it on hold because they're
all jacked up about getting the house
others are willing to wait a little bit
longer because they're all jacked up
about getting started with investing
so it's just personal preference there's
nothing on it so um i mean you can
actually add up what what is 15
equal uh what's your household income
rate of 70 000. okay all right so 15
is about 10 000 bucks a year
less that you would be putting towards
your down payment if you don't
temporarily stop investing now what i
don't want you to do
the only guideline i would give you is i
don't want you to stop investing
to do no baby step four for more than
three years
so you need to get your down payment
whatever you're gonna do if you're gonna
stop investing
if you're not gonna go to baby step four
uh you need to do whatever you're gonna
do inside of three years
and that's what the way i would get at
that hey thanks for the call
las cruces new mexico matt is on the
line hey matt how are you
you're all right how about yourself
better than i deserve how can i help
well i was just wondering i have about
eleven thousand
eighty three dollars in uh credit card
debt and i recently got an
ad in the mail i guess you could call it
uh to consolidate them
uh to get a much much lower interest
rate i'm
got 29 on all three credit cards
and the lower interest rate would be six
percent
yeah i'm just kind of wondering do you
think it's worth it to do that
or should i just forgo
consolidating them and continue to pay
on them as i've been what's your
household income
currently i am at 49
and eighty but as of july fifth i start
a new job
or i'll start there at fifty seven
thousand two hundred by december 2022
i'll be at sixty five thousand are you
single
no sir what does your wife make my wife
what does she make but um
well she just lost her job due to kobe
so she's just now another job she's also
pregnant i mean she just lost her job
just yeah
it's because she's pregnant oh and
can't get the shot right now because
we're afraid it might hurt the baby
that's why okay i'm with you on that
so right so what does she do
what does she do she is a prevention
specialist
she works with uh youngins
and trying to keep them off drugs
okay all right and how pregnant is she
we just started second trimester okay
all right
well i would look for something for her
to do
no we we are we're we're looking i mean
anything but but i mean i i would
because anything we can do
here's the thing okay 29 on 11 000
is 3 000 a year i would want you to pay
off 11 000
in six months so it's 1500 worth of
interest
that you're going to pay currently if
you reduce it to
uh six percent that's going to be about
300 so it's gonna save you about twelve
hundred dollars
in six months twelve hundred dollars is
nice if you hand it to me i'll take it
okay but would you notice that twelve
hundred dollars does not pay off eleven
thousand
he knows it so what pays off eleven
thousand is you getting on a beans and
rice rice and beans budget
and attacking this like your freaking
life depends on it
and you knock it out fast now if you're
gonna do that
we're talking about saving twelve
hundred dollars is all cause you're
gonna pay it off inside six months
that means that you are going to put two
thousand dollars a month on this debt
which means you're doing nothing nothing
except
working and paying on this stupid debt
that's killing you
now if you want to do that and reduce it
to six percent that's fine
but don't you dare reduce it to six
percent and walk off like you did
something
and then leave that debt laying there
you gotta pop it in the nose dude
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
open phones this hour this is the ramsay
show the phone number is triple eight
eight two five five two two five
thank you for joining us jeff is in
orlando hi jeff welcome to the ramsay
show
hey mr dave how are you sir better than
i deserve what's up
uh i i think i've made a mistake buying
a car
warranty and i'm wondering if i can
that cash out my car warranty to pay
down my loan
yes so they i
i wasn't sure i'd get about 22 000 left
on my car loan and if i cash it out
today
about three years early it'll give me
another
two thousand dollars to pay down on my
loan yes
i should i should just go ahead and do
that not warm but worry about the
warranty
yes all righty now let me back in
i appreciate you being so trustworthy of
my advice but let me tell you why okay
sure then you can decide okay extended
warranties
car warranties included are
87 profit
and overhead on average
they are 13 statistical probability of
coverage
now what that means is if we're going to
open up an insurance company of any kind
an extended
warranty company of any kind i don't
care what we're going to warranty
the first thing we would do is we would
figure out okay we're going to cover the
car
in this case against being against
breakdowns for xyz
and a b and c we're going to cover those
four things
then what we're going to do is we're
going to say this type of car a
i don't know a hyundai or whatever it is
okay just make up a brand
we're going to study that car for
breaking down on the items that we're
covering
and out of a thousand hyundai's just
like that
we're going to know that the average car
is going to break down
a certain number of times mathematically
out of a thousand we'll get some good
averages and so we know what it's going
to cost
us per car that we cover on average does
that make sense
it does so it's a statistical table it's
called an actuarial table in life
insurance
but anytime you're running a statistical
probability of an event occurring
like that you're doing you're studying
it's an actuarial study
okay and so that's all you're doing is
you're just figuring out
out of a thousand hyundais and we're
gonna cover let's just say let's just
make it simple it never happens but
let's say you're gonna buy
a transmission insurance and that's all
it was
then you would study a thousand hyundais
of that exact model and make
and say out of a thousand of them seven
of them the transmission is going to go
out
and the transmission costs this much
money and you divide that into times
seven divided into a thousand and we
know what it costs us per
car out of a thousand that we cover is
that one more time that logical that
makes sense to you
it does yeah that number that number is
thirteen percent
on average okay meaning that
that's all that they're covering you for
is thirteen dollars out of every hundred
one hundred and thirty dollars out of
every thousand two hundred and sixty
dollars out of every two thousand
so what i just told you to cancel was
260 dollars worth of coverage
and you got two thousand bucks back for
it
yeah that makes sense two years ago i
bought it with the warranty for 3200
so i've already had about hundred
dollars as uh you would say stupid tax
yeah yeah you've lost that unless you
had 1200
worth of repairs and you were one of the
seven people out of a thousand or
whatever the number is right in which
case you always feel like a genius for
buying these things
but statistically they the other 87
percent
on car warranties about 50 percent of it
is paid in commission to the dealer
so when you bought a 3200 warranty
somewhere around 1500 bucks went to that
dealer as a commission
and the rest of it went to uh 13 then
260 went to cover the actual event on
average
and the balance went to profit and
overhead for the warranty company that
sold it to the dealer
they made a profit in there as well but
about 50 percent of car warranty is
is actual commission and that's why best
buy when you're checking out for an
extended warranty
if you go to best buy and buy a number
two pencil they will try to put an
extended warranty on it
you know what i'm saying because they
make more money on extended warranties
on at best buy
and on credit cards and 90 days same as
cash
than they do on tvs their money that
they make is on extended warranties and
on financing
so and the car dealer is not much
different so all of that
is the reasoning behind this so what i
just ask you to do
is take 260 worth of risk
on average in return you reduce your
debt by 2 000
i think that's a good trade that's why i
told you to do it
sure absolutely two thousand dollars
closer to being debt free so i
appreciate it yeah
and you may have something break
tomorrow you know that right
yeah yeah yeah that's cause that's not
covered by your regular warranty
and therefore not covered by the
extended warranty so you're going to be
cussing dave ramsey then
unless you understood the risk that you
were taking and so that that's
but i never buy extended warranties on
anything
for that exact reason right there it's
simple math for me i will self-insure
through something
that gives me a 13 benefit out of a 100
dollar um it's just not worth it to me
it's you pay so dearly for the coverage
that's what it comes
down to open phones at triple eight
eight two five
five two two five uh jennifer's in
champaign
illinois hi jennifer how are you hello
dave i'm blessed today how are you
better than i deserve how can i help
okay i'm calling on behalf of my
daughter to see what i can do to
possibly
help her out of a situation that she has
gotten herself into
she's a single mom with two school-aged
kids
she has a good job where she makes about
32 dollars an hour
and has some excellent benefits with
that
unfortunately she has a lot of debt
and not a lot of assets in her case
what situation did she get herself into
she bought a house that was condemned
why with a gentleman because
she was with a significant other who
talked to her
well basically she went along with it
drank the kool-aid and went along with
the story
unfortunately her name is the only one
on the loan and it's a personal loan it
is not a house loan
so how much does she have on the
personal loan
um her personal loan is right around 24
000
is the property in her name it's in both
their names
where's goober where'd he go
oh he's not paying on it at all i know
is he still around
oh yes okay yes i don't think we can
help her
well that was what i thought but my
question is
with her debt is there a better way for
her to refinance
that as opposed to this personal loan
that she has
now she needs to sell the condition at
home as much as she can
as soon as she can and pay down the loan
as fast as she can
and probably evict goober
okay well she's no longer with goober i
thought you said he was still there
oh he's still in the city oh he's still
hanging around but he got all he wanted
out of this
okay now he's got half a house he wanted
out of this but this house is
in um it's most likely the city is going
to make them demolish it yeah i know
they're not there they're going to make
the new investor demolish it because
she's going to sell it this week
and guber is going to sign or i'm going
to threaten him within an inch of his
life
okay i like that yeah because he he's a
parasite
is what you've just described right
mm-hmm
yeah he needs to sign and they need to
get rid of this house i hope your
daughter is not
further in debt when the smoke clears
but the house is not encumbered by a
mortgage she just has a personal loan
of twenty four thousand dollars so she
gets eighteen thousand for the house
voila she's got an extra six thousand
dollars for having taken a trip with
goober
so it's not encumbered by a house loan
no you said it was a personal line
yes it is it's probably not got a lien
on the house they probably didn't take a
lien on the property because it probably
ain't worth that much
any idea what they paid for it
it was fifteen thousand dollars they
paid for it and then she took out a
personal loan
to do home improvements on a house that
would you
couldn't you could make it livable maybe
so she's living in
dollars no living with us
right now okay all right good there's no
way you could live in this it's a
horrible
horrible situation so again my question
was to see if there was anything that we
could do to advise her
i think let's cut let's cut bait let's
cut the losses as fast as we can
get him out of her life as fast as we
can and as far as we can permanently
and get this property out of her life
it's not going to be anything but a
money pit for her
she needs to get rid of it and if she
ends up a little bit in the hole
getting rid of it so be it that's part
of the price she paid for this bad
decision
i'm so sorry for her what a horrible
[Music]
thing
[Music]
our scripture today matthew 5 14 and 15
you're the light of the world a town
built on a hill
cannot be hidden neither do people light
a lamp and put it under a bowl instead
they put it on a stand and it gives
light to everyone
in the house albert schweitzer said at
times our
own light goes out and is rekindled by a
spark
from another person each of us has
caused to think with
deep gratitude of those who have lighted
the flame
within us agreed
so our last caller mom calling
grieving for her daughter who has
children
single mom she hooks up with a guy who's
a bad dude
he may not be intentionally bad dude
but he's stupid and he talks her into
getting on the stupid train with him
and together they buy a condemned house
for fifteen thousand and they put
another nine thousand in it and she has
twenty four thousand dollars
and she already had thirty two thousand
dollars in debt and she already was a
single mom barely making it living with
her mom
i have done a whole lot of stupid things
in my life
and i have coached and sat with people
and cried with people and prayed with
people that have done a whole lot of
stupid things in our life
most money problems
are self-inflicted
most of the time like
almost all the time that i have gotten
messed up in a money situation lost my
tail in
was because i was stupid
and you know when i'm the dumbest the
same time that poor girl was
i'm the dumbest when i'm desperate
right after i get desperate i get really
stupid
because when you get desperate you will
grab at things and try
to do things that you know in your mind
are not going to work but somewhere deep
down in your heart you think you're
going to win the lotto so you buy the
ticket
knowing you're not you think you're
going to beat the odds
you look at this guy standing in front
of your young woman and you know he's a
twerp
but you're so desperate that you try to
hook up with him anyway
he tries to talk you into buying a
freaking condemned house
and you know this is not gonna work but
you're so
desperate that you tried anyway and now
we've got an extra tens of thousands of
dollars worth of problems
this hurts so bad i'm so sorry
and some people don't like it that i
call some of these things that people do
stupid oh ramsay just calls you stupid
ramsay calls himself stupid so we're all
stupid we're all on
we've all bought a ticket a time or two
on the stupid train i'm not
saying anything that i haven't done or
you know i've done stupid with zeros on
the end so i'm not picking on any
body or shaming anybody but i mean just
be
careful when you're the most vulnerable
when you're the most desperate because
that's the most time you're gonna fall
into the trap
when you're desperate for companionship
you'll overlook the fact that this guy
is just
mentally ill when you're desperate
to get out of your mother's basement you
overlook the fact that this real estate
deal is a
horrible idea desperate
always leads to stupid
high probability of stupid is following
desperate be
careful folks jonathan's with us in
houston
texas hey jonathan welcome to the ramsay
show
hi dave how's it going better than i
deserve what's up
i want to know how you handle family
members
in an estate situation i'm over the
estate my sister's over
overseas my mom's finances but every
month at the end of the month she's
basically drained down my mom's social
security check
i'm sorry how are you over oh your mom's
still alive
yes i'm also alive my dad died recently
and left the estate
to my mom i'm the trustee she's a
beneficiary
okay so how is your sister over the
money if you're the trustee of the
estate and all
the money is in your control this
the money that my sister is dealing with
is my mom's social security money that's
coming in
oh that's all i'm only oh yes my lawyer
says that
i'm only over the estate i'm not over
the social security
right that's true you don't have control
of that okay and so
uh your sister is using up your mom's
only money to live on
yes she doesn't have a job hasn't had a
job in several years till it's at home
wow and how old is she
about 42. okay
you hold your mom 72 with alzheimer's
oh wait is she um is she still is she
lost her capacity
no not yet she's still
functioning day to day um but she lost
her decision-making ability
no when you ask her direct questions she
can definitely answer that but
if you leave with something that's
opening that you will ramble on and kind
of
drift off okay so
let me tell you i mean you can go as
hard on this as you want to go
one is you can just let this run its
course and not worry about it and you
just make sure your mom's taken care of
because soon enough your sister's gonna
have nothing when your mom passes
correct she's gonna be out on her own
she's gonna figure it out then that's
gonna happen soon enough
uh if you to go harder on it you can sit
down face to face with your sister and
say listen
here's what's coming when mom's gone
you're gonna be out you'll get your
share of the inheritance
because that's what the will says and i
will abide by the will but you're not
going to be here anymore
you're not going to be staying i'm sorry
i've done sit downs with her
over four times my friends have told her
some of the things i told her and she
still doesn't listen
she just keeps on going the only other
thing you can do
if you want to go hard and i don't think
i would recommend this
but um you would have to have your mom
declared incompetent
and have the court apport appoint what's
called a guardian that light on someone
to watch over your mom
which would likely be you at which point
you would evict your sister
that's pretty hardcore your mom's not
going to enjoy that process
your sister's not going to enjoy that
process therefore you're not going to
enjoy that process
and truthfully i mean what's your mom's
life expectancy do you think
five years four years three years
five years i'm i'm giving it i mean you
know we're
current condition right now yeah it's
pretty easy to say
five years probably or less yeah issues
yeah i'm not medical but i mean you've
got you've got
a medium level of all summers and so
it's always debilitating so i don't know
anything about it i've just worked with
enough of these situations looking in
from the outside
so i mean it's up to you do you want to
let this uh
i i you don't need the social security
money it doesn't
do anything for you it just aggravates
you that your sister is a parasite
it does i'm i'm trying to make sure that
i paid off
all my debts once my dad passed away i
made sure that all the investments are
up to snuff
so that my mom will have if she needs
any assisted living nursing home
anything like that there's
money there to take care of her for five
six seven years
but my sister doesn't understand that
like we need an emergency fund i saved
up a lot of money
and bought a new washer dryer because it
went out of the house because my sister
didn't have the money saved up
and i'd tell her these things and try to
explain it to her and nothing gets
through here and i'm just wondering like
what i would do is sooner rather than
later i would get your mom
in a different situation for care
and just sell the house
you're in charge of the house are you
not yes yeah
okay so when your mom doesn't need to
live there anymore and needs care
i would get her in an assisted living
situation even if it's a nice high-end
you know partially functional but then
just tell your sisters you know you have
to move because the house has been so
and that that gets her that may not get
her out of the social security but it
gets her out of everything
else yes
and it gives her the wake-up call that
bless her heart at 42 she needs because
she's not productive she's not happy
she's miserable
every day every day i told her she's
miserable just
there's no dignity in the way she's
living it's not fun for her either it's
just sad
but the problem is she's got some kind
of mental thing going where she's in
denial about
what her life's gonna look like so i
really wouldn't
i can't recommend you go hardcore on it
but if you want to you'd be
understandable
that you did but i i think um you know
just
but please don't continue to expect your
sister to change ever
she's not going to change all that's
going to happen is she's just going to
become homeless
and then she's going to change but
you're not going to change her you're
not going to talk her out of this
i'm sorry that's so painful i'll put
sass hour of the ramsey show in the
books we'll be back with you before you
know it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
prince of peace
christ jesus
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show you can listen to all our
shows with the ramsay network app on
your smartphone browse by topic or even
sync clips to your friends
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
you